mich hat heute eine Nachricht entsetzt
und ja ich muss auch sagen verstört denn
Schweden hat den moderner Impfstoff für
junge Erwachsene unter 30 jetzt erstmal
ausgesetzt also wenn man unter 30
bekommt man jetzt erstmal nicht mehr
moderner verabreicht dänemark hat gleich
gezogen da ist aber bei den unter
18-Jährigen also die unter 18-Jährigen
in Dänemark kriegen nicht mehr moderner
verabreicht und in Schweden die unter
30-Jährigen ich habe natürlich dann muss
ich gestehen direkt in der Sekunde an
Freundin von mir gedacht die den
moderner Impfstoff verabreicht bekommen
haben in Deutschland zum Glück hatten
die auch nichts denn das muss man jetzt
hier sagen das sind sehr sehr geringer
Teil hatte Nebenwirkungen weswegen der
jetzt erstmal ausgesetzt wird aber es
gibt halt ein sehr geringes Risiko von
Herzmuskelerkrankungen und da ist jetzt
Schweden und Dänemark einfach mal vorweg
gegangen und haben ihn bis Dezember
erstmal ausgesetzt und was wünsch ich
mir von Deutschland oft ist Deutschland
einen anderen Weg gegangen als Schweden
und Dänemark oft fand ich das schlecht
jetzt finde ich es auch schlecht und ich
finde Deutschland sollte folgen
Deutschland muss auch Moder prüfen
lassen ich möchte aber noch mal ganz
klar erwähnen bevor ich die Runde
eröffne es wurde wirklich damit hier
keine Panikmache entsteht in Dänemark
und Schweden auch nur ein sehr sehr
geringer Teil hatte diese
Herzmuskelerkrankungen das Risiko ist
nach wie vor bei moderner sehr gering
laut den neuesten Meldungen aus Schweden
und Dänemark trotzdem finde ich
Deutschland sollte sich anschließend
Deutschland muss moderner überprüfen
lassen also wenn wir was in Deutschland
können Nena dann glaube ich ist es
prüfen ja wie oft habe ich den Satz in
letzter Zeit gehört das müssen wir
prüfen ich glaube das unentwegt in
Deutschland alles geprüft wird zehn mal
20 mal und wenn wir überhaupt ein
Problem in der corona-krise hatten dann
war es dass wir zu viel geprüft haben zu
vorsichtig waren zu langsam waren zu
viel Angst hatten zu viel Panik gemacht
haben jetzt kommst du um die Ecke und
sagst da ist schon wieder zieht schon
wieder die nächste Angst auf vor dem
Impfstoff ich würde mich hier live
sofort mit moderner impfen lassen heute
abend noch mal ich finde wir haben eine
zu vorsichtige Diskussion auch um eine
dritte Impfung das müsste hier
eigentlich auf den Tisch warum impfen
wir nicht längst flächendeckend moderner
als drittimpfung und wie gesagt in
Deutschland haben wir viel zu viel Angst
verbreitet waren viel zu vorsichtig in
dieser corona-krise und ich habe volles
Vertrauen dass unsere Behörden wenn die
überhaupt eines können dann können die
prüfen aber in Schweden bitte jetzt
Bayern Tag anstelle davon verabreicht
werden und auch Dänemark hat das gerade
gemacht ich muss ehrlich sagen ich sehe
das anders ich hatte beide ersten also
die ersten zweite Impfung hatte ich mit
biontech deswegen ich glaube ich weiß
gar nicht ob man es drittimpfung dann
überhaupt moderner wählen könnte wenn
man schon bayerntag hat ich glaube man
bleibt dann wahrscheinlich bei dem
gleichen Impfstoff aber ich sehe das
nicht so ich meine Schweden ist ja nicht
das Land was alles überprüft hat in
Schweden waren die Hallen offen die
Kinder konnten Fußball spielen während
in Deutschland die Kinder vom
Fußballplatz nur träumen konnten also
Schweden ist für mich nicht das Land das
panikland was alles direkt überprüft und
das ja aber genau deswegen muss es doch
für Deutschland jetzt ein Signal sein
okay vielleicht schließen wir uns mal an
wie siehst Du das denn ja aber die
Ständige Impfkommission ist ja oder auch
die immer auf europäischer Ebene war
auch mein an und den teile ich mit
teilweise auf jeden Fall das eigentlich
dort sehr seriös geprüft wurde dass es
eigentlich auch gar keine Ratschläge aus
anderen Ländern bedurfte sondern dass da
die deutschen Fachleute eigentlich
extrem gut geprüft haben sehr
gewissenhaft eigentlich die Themen
angegangen sind geimpft haben haben wir
immer noch geprüft ja das muss man auch
mal sehen also von daher glaube ich aber
das Thema Panik und du hast selbst
gesagt du willst keine Panik jetzt
verbreiten aber wir haben ja heute beim
Thema Panik auch schon wieder Neues
gehört also lotharina der RKI Chef der
ja in gewisser Weise schon wieder neue
Panik auch verbreitet die man plötzlich
gesagt hat ja zwischen Corona und Grippe
gebe es doch sehr sehr viele
Gemeinsamkeiten also hat die Grippe
quasi auf eine Stufe mit Corona gehoben
was eigentlich bisher ja eher immer nur
Querdenker sogenannte querlänger gemacht
haben ich glaube da wird er wieder neue
Panik geschürt und das ist schlecht aber
ja dann sagen wir jetzt mal nur noch
einen Fall wir im Moment wird ja für
jeden der sich nicht impfen lassen will
das wird ja gesellschaftlich ist ja die
gesellschaftliche Ächtung ja wirklich
schon bei 100%. was ich mich aber jetzt
Frage Schweden und Dänemark sagen es
gibt im geringen Risiko bei den unter
30-Jährigen es waren wohl vor allem
Männer betroffen seltene
herzmuskelentzündungen das ist für mich
dann keine Panikmache sondern finde ich
schon okay dann müssen wir jetzt mal
billigen vor allem auch bei den jüngeren
Kindern U18 wo er eh vieles auch
asymptomatisch verläuft und da finde ich
jetzt schon dass man überlegen muss okay
schon auch Risiken gegeneinander weiß
ich zumindest hätte ich die Debatte
gerade schon gerne in Deutschland wie
siehst du es denn also es zeigt erstmal
dass es nicht die Wissenschaft gibt weil
die Wissenschaftler in anderen Ländern
sind ja nicht weniger seriös deswegen
ist es eigentlich schon erstaunlich dass
in verschiedenen Ländern verschiedene
Ergebnisse
herauskommen
deswegen ist es für mich eigentlich eher
ein Signal dass man das auf jeden Fall
umso mehr untersuchen sollte je
unterschiedlichere Ergebnisse
Wissenschaftler auch in Studien dann
herausfinden natürlich ist es immer noch
eine seltene Geschichte das ist auch gut
so das wurde jetzt auch in vielen
Studien schon geprüft aber
nichtsdestotrotz wenn bei der Impfung
die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher ist als bei
anderen gewöhnlichen Impfungen sollte
das schon Grund zu Annahme sein oder
Grund zu Sorge sein dass man das ganze
noch mal überprüfen sollte und wie du
auch schon gesagt hast ich finde die
Impfquote finde ich persönlich gar nicht
so gering weil Kinder sind da drunter
ich glaube wir haben fast 15 Prozent
Kinderanteil oder unter 18-Jährige sage
ich mal erstens und zweiten und zweitens
werden die genesenen fast nie mit in
diese Rechnung einbezogen aber ist unser
Problem eigentlich jetzt dass wir zu
wenig Impfstoff haben oder ist unser
Problem eigentlich dass ich zu wenig
Menschen in Deutschland noch impfen
lassen weil
verzichtet im Sommer wir haben schon im
Sommer darauf weitere Lieferung das
Problem glaube ich eher auch wirklich
ein anderes also die den und die
Schweden die können ja in dem Fall
machen was sie wollen unsere Fachleute
bin mir sicher dass die das auch immer
weiter
Problem was wir in Deutschland haben ist
eher dass das offenbar die Impfquote
noch nicht so hoch ist wie man sich das
eigentlich gewünscht hat dass also
eigentlich die die Maßnahmen verstärken
werden müssten zu gucken wie bekommen
wir eigentlich noch mehr Menschen oder
zu einem piekst oder den Pix in die Arme
der Menschen und ich glaube da ist das
Thema moderner
vier fünf Monaten geimpft ja und ich
habe für mich eigentlich damit
abgeschlossen und es muss jeder wissen
es gibt immer ein kleines Risiko 100%
Sicherheit gibt es nie ja und wenn man
eben ich glaube dass die Nebenwirkungen
geringer sind wie eine Krankheit ja wie
ein Ausbruch hatten sie Nebenwirkung hat
irgendwas weh der Arm oder ich hatte
auch keine Nebenwirkungen und mein
ganzer Freund ist Bekanntenkreis die
Verwandten auch nicht ja und ich weiß
noch nicht mal mehr jetzt mit was ich
mich habe impfen lassen komisch
normalerweise kommt immer wie so ein
status symbol welche Impfstoff war es
denn am Anfang als die Impfung gerade
kam hat jeder gefragt womit wurde
da muss ich nur einmal hin aber dann
hatte ich schon ein anderes und ich
meine für mich ist immer das Risiko
geringer als dann nachher der Nutzen und
ein drittes Mal impfen lassen würden sie
sich auch wahrscheinlich oder einfach
noch mal als zusätzlichen
Abenteurer bin ja und weil ich nicht
krank sein möchte okay aber
verzichtet man eher auf den wenn sie in
die andere ich habe Verständnis wenn die
Leute sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
und jeden Tag ich habe mich so oft
testen lassen dass ich jetzt froh bin
dass ich mich wenigstens immer jeden Tag
testen lassen muss für irgendeinen Job
also war es auch eine Impfung für die
Freiheit ja absolut ja kann ich echt
sagen und ich habe das Risiko dass ich
Nebenwirkungen habe einfach
runtergeschluckt ja wie so oft im Leben
aber wo ist er denn der Impfstoff für
die drittimpfung ich habe das gerade
schon mal kurz gesagt eigentlich müssten
doch jetzt massenweise in Altenheimen
müssten da müssen die Busse hinfahren
und sofort wieder die drittimpfung
anbieten in den sozialen Berufen wo die
Impfung eben schon lange her ist wo im
Januar im Februar im März geimpft wurde
dann müssten jetzt äh massiv die Teams
reingehen und sofort wieder den in
Schweden liegen gebliebenen moderner
Impfstoff verimpfen ja das fehlt an
Debatte meiner Ansicht nach ja schon
hunderttausende von Dosen die nicht
verimpft werden ja klar
Impfung die führen wir bisher gar nicht
ja also das ist eine Gefühle doch jetzt
also wir brauchen mit anderen Worten
genau
ja einfach machen
wir den live-impfung demnächst hier
ist besprochen Hans Ulrich Jörges nicht
werden uns bei viertel nach acht den
dritten Pieks geben lassen Hans Ulrich
Jürgen ich habe schon abgesprochen
ich habe das Gefühl du wärst auch dabei
hier live würdest es auch machen
ich hoffe dass irgendwann das Ding
wieder ein Dynamik gewinnt wie so vieles
im Leben und das dann der Drops
gelutscht ist
[Musik]